the
how's your classes going
dub the first thing we wrote on paper
was we want the guy who wrote the police
to play the police captain in our ROV
police straight from the Magic Johnson
nice cuber my childhood Heroes well I
probably annoyed him with every NWA Ice
Cube fre Kings Friday question ever
there's an incident between him and Jona
it's it's it's one of those scenes that
people are going to
remember captain
they get a kick out of seeing me yell at
Channing and and Jonah I always found it
funny to be yelled at by Ice Cube so the
more he yelled at me the more I thought
it was funny clearly I wasn't talking to
you big titties you cherub looking
mother